so you didn't leave on your own he let  you go he said goodbye he go he let me  go Wow um I was shocked too you know I  was pretty heartbroken when it happened  but I moved on I guess he was looking  for something else  whoo-hoo his loss yes new Bachelorette  Rachel Lindsay opening up to Ellen  DeGeneres revealing what she's looking  for in a man now that she's done with  Nick file I really don't have a physical  type except for a great smile I'm a  sucker for a great smile I'm looking for  a guy who can make me laugh I'm looking  for a guy who knows exactly what he  wants who's ambitious ready to start a  family ready to get married cuz I'm at  that phase of my life with the 31 year  olds also hints that she knows who Nick  gave his final rose to and get this she  loves this season Fillon Corinne I love  Fred can't just put that out there  unfortunately you only get to see some  sides of Corinne you know I got to see  all sides living in the house with her  [Music]